the harpy a mythical creature in Greek
mythology with the body of a bird and
the face of a woman the harpies were
known as the hounds of Zeus as they
would often be dispatched to do his
bidding on earth they were sent as a
form of punishment stealing food from
their victims and even carrying some
away to be judged by the goddess of
retribution and vengeance their name
translated means snatches which is
reflected in their actions as they would
swoop down and snatch people away from
earth the harpies were sometimes seen as
spirits of the wind and in some Greek
poems they were not physical beings at
all rather the storm winds personified
the appearance of the harpy is one that
varies in Greek mythology in early
stories they were described as fairlock
to winged maidens with Grecian pottery
depicting harpies as beautiful women
with wings the later depictions of
harpies described them as ugly and
disgusting creatures who gave off a
putrid odor they will cruel and
terrifying of a ravenous hunger they had
sharp talons made of metal that they
would use slash and shred their victims
some believed that they were the cousins
of the Gorgons the three sisters of hair
made of venomous snakes and the gaze
that could turn anyone into stone one of
the most well-known stories involving
harpies is that of Jason and the
Argonauts and King Phineas of Thrace
Zeus gave Phineas the gift of prophecy
and in return he used it against the
gods as punishment Zeus blinded the king
and he was sentenced to live on an
island of a buffet of food that he could
never eat the harpies would swoop down
every morning and steal all of the food
before Phineas was able to satisfy his
hunger years later Phineas was rescued
from his fate by Jason and the Argonauts
as they drove the harpies away in this
story we can see the harpies or an agent
of punishment
as with many creatures in Greek
mythology they have been known to evolve
with time the harpies were once
considered desirable and majestic
creatures they later became ugly cruel
monsters who were used as an agent of
punishment against evildoers if you've
enjoyed this video then please go ahead
and leave it a like consider subscribing
if folklore mythology is something that
interests you if you have anything you'd
like to discuss or have any ideas for
future videos then please go ahead and
let me know in the comments below as
always I've been your host mythology and
folklore explained